hello everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at South by Southwest we
are so happy to be here thanks to our
great sponsors like El Tesoro tequila
because these are the companies that are
letting us talk about some really cool
movies that you should be aware of one
of which is pink wall and I am here with
the filmmakers behind it again I already
told you I really loved your movie so a
huge congratulations on this I wanted to
start with you Tom because it isn't easy
to get a first feature off the ground so
I was curious did you kind of just wake
up one morning and say I want to do this
and just take the plunge well it's
actually something that I've always
wanted to do I became an actor in many
ways because I wanted to understand the
psyche of an actress that I could be a
better director and then I fell in love
hard with acting and my acting career
took off and the co-directing moved the
side and but it always been the back of
my head of something I wanted to do and
then a director that I worked with
before he's also producer his name's
Jamie Adams great director he he called
me up offering me a job on his next film
and unfortunately my schedule couldn't
wasn't right and I couldn't do it but we
got chatting and JE Duplass and Mark
Duplass kind of came up in our
conversations I don't know why I can't
remember why but I was kind of like oh
man
JT pass I love that guy I'm I've kind of
had this idea for this movie in my head
for JT placement a to do together and I
kind of weirdly soft pitched it over the
phone by accident to Jamie and Jamie was
like this sounds kind of cool and will
you write me a one-pager
okay what's a one-pager
never done that before but sure I'll do
that so I wrote up a garbled load of
nonsense and send it across and Jamie
Fermi back I think was the next day or
the day after saying well I've got you a
budget for the film if you would like to
make it you have to make it in like
three or four months and I just was like
[ __ ] it
yeah why not I'm gonna I'm going to do
that I'm going to be way you make your
first feature is bias
[ __ ] yeah it was great because because
I'm on a TV show which takes up 6-7
months of my year and I just kind of sat
perfectly in between my seasons and I
was just it you know it's nice when
someone forces you to do something
because I I think like a lot of people
you know fear stops us from doing those
things and it certainly does me and so
it was really nice to just kind of like
put that fear in the bin for once and
just you know go for it if you don't
have that fear I feel like you don't
care enough so whenever I feel like that
I kind of hold on to it and use it as
added motivation that's good looking on
the bright side here had YouTube met
before jumping into the specific project
and given the amount of history and
chemistry that kind of radiates off the
screen I imagine you probably had to
have a little bit of rehearsal in
pre-pro before jumping in yeah I mean I
think we'd met on we'd had a meeting and
then met on red carpets in a very
unnatural an artistic way but Tom built
in this great rehearsal kind of jam time
that we got before we started doing the
film a couple months before so he would
take us to like a loft space room and we
would improvise scenes and he give us
secrets that we had from each other and
sort of wants and and we got to really
explore these characters and kind of
discover them discover the dynamic
through very like organic totally
private like on you know unresolved
based improv which was which allowed us
to have like I guess a history in like a
shorthand that we yeah that was kind of
what they were designed for was I wanted
to actually build memories in their head
so that when certain things happened in
the film those memories would trigger in
some kind of capacity even if even if it
isn't conscious it kind of exists
somewhere within them the all the improv
that we did all the scenarios that I
built were part of the film so a lot of
it was to do with their relationship
their dynamics with their parents as
some of some of it was to do with the
dynamics of of their own relationship
for example
in the film there's a there's a one of
the tipping points of the film is a
painting of tatts character jenna done
by her grandfather that goes missing and
so I improvised we-we-we created a scene
where it was the night after the
painting had gone missing and they they
improvised that scenario and so whatever
it is it kind of it will always just
vibrate and exists within them during
the scenes so what kind of notes do you
two have before jumping into a scene and
also now that it's crossing my mind do
you get to shoot this kind of in
chronological order rather than film
water so you can kind of build as you go
along I think we shot in beard order I'm
not kidding
because we changed the look a lot and
the beard was really the limiting factor
like we so slowly chipped away at a big
fat sloppy stoner beard and that's the
guiding principle organizing principle
of this film it was all done Jay's beard
the reduction the slow can sculpting
it's a deal I feel like people don't
really think about that how difficult it
is to create a fake realistic looking
beard so you got to work it into the
schedule that way yeah we really did I'm
in prep I was kind of like googling
images of Jay to see what kind of what I
could do with him and this image of him
with the moustache popped up and I was
just like wow that he looks good so that
was that was what we built the schedule
around was Jay's mustache clearly Jay
got to infuse a little of himself into
that role are there any parts with your
character that you particularly connect
to or something about yourself that you
implanted in her oh yeah I mean Jenna's
Jenna I love Jenna so much and Tom and I
had been talking about that character
and about sort of the lack of of her in
cinema and and sort of you know our own
experiences Tom having so many women in
his life who he admired and
he was fascinated by her had
relationships with or whatever and sort
of pulling a lot from myself as well
kind of collaborating on that you know
you know I'm feel like I'm like this
collaborating on that in a in a real
personal way and obviously we have you
know our relationship to draw from as
well in terms of what we've experienced
together and and and where we see people
in our lives you know struggling with
what it what it is when when one person
starts growing or when someone's
evolving in a relationship and sort of
betrays that dynamic that you've
established in the early days how do you
grow with each other so yeah like most
movies don't really dig into the nuance
of something like that and especially
how messy it can get so it's very
refreshing to have something that really
kind of digs deep and gets into those
dark corners like this I was also
curious for you because I remember years
ago I mean you know I'm a huge fan of
orphan black and I remember so long ago
there were the ro1 rumors and then
seeing what you've done recently I mean
with this and you know I'm thinking
about destroyer I'm just curious after
orphan black kind of what your
priorities are and what really pulls you
into a specific project because I would
like to bet you have your pick I mean
it's always been the same thing really
since I was a kid it's character and
it's and I and I'm so hungry for
characters that are complicated and and
and and processes like this where improv
and where personal experience and where
the space that Tom held on the set was
so safe and every single crew member
felt like they could collaborate like
they had a voice in it which is so
unusual where every actor had complete
ownership over what they were saying and
what their point of view was that that's
that kind of process is so rare and it
doesn't matter what other stuff comes
along it's always if that's on the table
it's like a no-brainer you know to say a
blockbuster can't have that degree of no
elaboration sure intimacy but would
something like if I don't know what
superhero role came knocking on your
door would you be in
interested in something like that or do
you like the more kind of I guess
grounded collaborative free-flowing
approach to an independent film it's all
up for grabs I just like I like
collaboration on whatever level that is
you know and and I think you can find it
all over the place you just have to ally
yourself with the right people and and
really seek it out yeah but but
obviously I think on a small scale
people don't can take bigger risks and I
think what's so cool about pink wall is
that Tom took really big visual
storytelling risks in and did it with
you know full support from the cast and
crew and from the producers and
everybody to really follow his vision
and I think that it's sometimes some
something that you can only do on a
smaller kind of budget or you know I
don't know maybe not but I do think
about that I think there's freedom there
yeah I think probably on the larger
scale you just need a really strong
leader who has all that sway to create
that kind of environment because there's
so many other assets in play that you
have to make do on whereas you're kind
of just going with what feels right here
and I was looking for you guys to maybe
paint a picture of what the set looks
like in that last scene without spoiling
anything because it's such a it's such a
deeply emotional scene and it's also
super isolated so I was wondering if
maybe the camera tilted over just the
slightest bit would I see base camp and
a whole bunch of crew and lights around
you or do you really have that intimacy
on set in a small group that was
something I really wanted was a skeleton
crew um I feel like what's great when
you have a small crew is that everyone
knows and feels that they are a very
important part of the Machine because
they are and everyone is invested into
the story and I kind of hand-picked a
group of people that I've worked with
throughout my life who I admire and love
working with who have become great
friends and you know people came from
all over the world to be a part of the
film and so I wanted to create an
environment that felt really safe and
really supportive and they were scenes
when I would kick everybody out and we
just have the bare minimum people you
know be the camera operators
and the boom operator and me and the
actors and that would be it you know
really create an environment where they
felt safe enough to just disappear
and the mountain scene I mean when you
when you're on something we had nine
days to shoot it and so everything is
kind of really high octane in many ways
and you know we were supposed to have
ten days but to shoot the whole thing to
shoot the whole thing we're supposed to
ten days but this storm called Brian
came in and and and took one of our days
away and that last scene that you're
talking about we were supposed to have a
day to shoot that but because of old
Brian you know you're not bright you
know Brian you're familiar with Brian
we've all met Brian yeah my coat was
very familiar with Brian it still is we
actually had to shoot that that scene in
Ford in four hours and so we were
actually less I think maybe and so it
was really important to create a dynamic
for those two that felt really secure
and safe and I mean if you pan to the
right there's just a load of people
leaving the freezing cold that's that's
it really yeah
do you guys like that kind of vibe
because sometimes they feel like yeah
you don't want anything to go wrong but
sometimes when something does go wrong
you find kind of this magic hidden
somewhere where you wouldn't have found
it before yeah I mean that environment
in particular was so unbelievably
immersive it was it's hard to describe
how cold and how wet it actually was and
the sort of trudging that we were doing
I mean it's basically like some dark ass
weathering hide [ __ ] like when people
say they died in a bog I didn't
understand until I was like there in a
[ __ ] bog like you literally could
take the wrong step and just like
disappear until I did I was running
luckily and everyone was like don't run
don't run but I was like my kind of
thinking is look if I'm making everyone
do this I'm the one that has to work the
hardest and get the wettest and carry
the most heavier
as you did that and I was and I was
running and thank God I was running
because I was I stepped on this bit of
grass and I went I mean I disappeared
and it was right next to a waterfall and
luckily I was running so only my leg
went down not to about here but my other
leg was out and they kind of pulled me I
was like okay I think I was gonna like I
would have liked God I have a major soft
spot for horror movies and that just
feels like like a final destination also
I mean just to the credit of the
environment that Tom created and the
intimacy that he created I mean I'm sure
you guys have experienced actors too
when you're in extremely tremendously
trying physical circumstances with an
environment and weather and stuff a lot
of times it's really hard to get the
emotion and this is like the scene right
as as devastated as we were by the
environment I felt totally connected and
that's because of the world that Tom
created where you know we were shivering
and frozen and still like totally
focused on that moment I mean I think in
the end the four hours was like weirdly
perfect because I don't think we could
have stood out there I remember like
when we got it I was like I'm out of
juice like I'm literally out of words
like I'm heart my face is having a hard
time moving at this point you know it
was like and the movie had a lot of
kismet in that way it was just like
charging towards its destination in that
and that sort of like primal energy web
that's all I mean I can create an
environment but it takes actors to to be
brave enough to jump in there and you
know I'm not going to take credit for
that at all these two are absolutely
extraordinary I'm so lucky to have them
in my film and you know they they they
went in deep and they really dove and
they looked after each other it was it
was really humbling to watch these two
actors create a space for each other
that was generous and really caring but
so brave and and that's that's actually
them you know that's not me really these
they're amazing I love hearing about
things like that's that is part of the
reason why I love covering festivals
like South by Southwest I'm a firm
believer that a film set isn't just a
place where people go to work it is
where a family creates something that's
important to them you get that vibe from
here you guys talk about it and you get
the vibe from the film as well so I'm
gonna thank you so much for being here
right now to remind everybody out there
keep an eye out for pink wall from the
supper suite at South by Southwest in
Austin thanks for watching
we'll see you soon
you